my name is
john
fetter woman
[Applause]
my name is
dave rubin this is the reuben report
it's september 13th 2022 we're live
streaming on rumble youtube and blaze tv
subscribe tap the notification bell etc
and that cold open we just showed you
there if you're not paying attention to
national politics i don't think we've
done anything on the pennsylvania senate
race but that is john fetterman slash
fetter woman because pandering no no
knows no bounds with these people uh who
is running against uh newly minted
republican let's say uh dr oz tv host dr
oz and fetterman this guy has just been
an abject
disaster at every possible level we're
going to get to him in a little bit
because i'm going to sort of lay out the
case that a series of people that are
put into positions of power either
politically or in the media get
everything wrong and then they always
fail up i call this gavin newsom
syndrome if you do everything wrong in
your career if everything that you touch
turns to poop and you keep getting
better jobs
that is a sort of democrat privilege
which as i often say is the only
privilege really in america
so the democrats that's what they do
they fail up and it doesn't matter if
it's just politicians it's also media
people it's the analysts it's the
journalists it's the entire thing uh but
i think it's time
for us to realize especially uh
postcovid although they still think
we're in covid uh that all the people
who got everything wrong we can't just
kind of be like okay we should pay
attention to you again we gotta start
figuring out a better way to deal with
these people but before we get to any of
that joe biden yesterday he gave a
couple speeches there were so many
gaffes so many
slurred words so much complete nonsense
so much
reading off a teleprompter having no
idea what he was saying that we had like
10 of these clips that we were going to
show you this morning and just go one
after the other just to start the show
off on a on a biden gaffe
machine
however i thought right before we
started i said guys it's a little
gratuitous can we just do one let's just
pick the best one
uh so here's joe biden telling a bunch a
bunch of cancer patients not to jump off
a ledge
and i want to thank all of you the
cancer patients survivors caregivers and
don't jump from up there okay
nothing like telling a bunch of uh
cancer patients and survivors not to
jump from the high ledge that their good
god help us all okay so let's get to it
so i wanted to start with this clip of
bill maher and you guys know my feelings
about bill maher i don't have to belabor
them i am going to los angeles on the
21st of this month that's like a week
from today or something like that to sit
down and do bill maher's uh club random
podcast this is a two hour uncensored
conversation with him i hope i'm gonna
be able to bring up all the stuff i'm
always talking about here and as you
know when i criticize the guy i try to
do it respectfully i think he is the
last sane liberal and really that kind
of makes you a conservative at this
point anyway he's got a a new podcast
that he's doing from his home and they
do it while he's either smoking weed or
drinking booze i've told them the
tequila that i want during this thing so
we'll get liquored up and see what
happens anyway he had green bay packers
quarterback aaron rodgers on the show
this week and aaron rodgers has become
one of the most outspoken
anti-covid mandate and lockdown uh
athletes regardless of sport across the
the sport spectrum uh so rogers went on
the podcast and they started talking
about covid policies and vaccines and
who did what and when they did it and
well you tell me if some of this stuff
makes sense to me the frightening thing
was never the disease itself the
frightening thing was how much you could
you could get people
so quickly to change
their way of life
stay home wear a mask
you know don't do it was altruistic at
first it's like uh yeah yeah
and then
just about well every conspiracy theory
came true vaccine mandates vaccine
passports right
and it turned into like away from doing
your job to stop the
the spread to like lockdowns and that's
my whole problem
you know i grew up in a small town very
little
cases up in chico california but all the
small businesses [ __ ] gone i mean our
favorite restaurants in la and new york
and across the country not just in big
cities
but
some crazy percentage will never open
again why absolutely and then what are
we doing for them
what are we doing for the small
businesses there was some ppe loans and
stuff that people could file for we did
we passed out six trillion dollars
and the
sad fact about that is that a very big
big big chunk of it was just flat out
stolen yeah
i mean we spent more to keep people
hiding under the bed
than we did for world war ii world war
ii cost 4 trillion and we passed out
almost 6 trillion for this i mean wow
talk about a country that's gone a
little soft
okay so the reason i wanted to show you
that clip is because this is where i'm
going to really try to push bill it's
like he gets it it does not work when
the government comes in and shuts you
down and tells you if you can go to
school or can go to work or should be
injected or all those things and then
gives you money back and again the
government is never giving you money
it's taking money from some people and
giving it to other people it's not the
government's money it's your money right
he gets that that doesn't even work the
giant bureaucracy all of the stuff
doesn't work but what i really wanted to
focus on in this clip uh because it gets
to the theme of everything else i want
to do today is is the beginning of that
where he talks about how the frightening
thing to him wasn't the disease it was
all of the other things how quickly
people would give up their freedoms in
two weeks to flatten the curve and
social distancing and all of those other
things now i've discussed this many
times and since all of my videos are
still online at least for now you can go
back and check i grant everybody i
really mean this i grant everybody
regardless if you're a crazy lefty
progressive or you're a far-right maniac
i grant everybody during those first two
weeks of covid we were all so nuts
and maybe that was by design okay i'm
not even defending whether we all should
have been saner or not but for those
first two weeks when it was just hey two
weeks shut it down social distance wear
a mask we all kind of did it everyone
did it
and i think you got to grant everybody a
long leash we were we were shell-shocked
in this crazy thing now maybe it was all
made up to some degree and it was a
media
a media con
was made up just the whole thing right
like a conspiracy okay fine whatever
whatever it was
um but i grant everybody a long leash on
that and then it was very obvious to me
and as i said since my videos are all
online you can go back and check like
after two weeks i pretty much was done i
pretty much was done i was fighting for
freedom the idea that you can wear a
mask if you want to wear a mess but we
shouldn't be locking things down i knew
once everyone started saying once the
meme came out and everyone online and in
the media kept saying this is the new
normal and the way they liked it and
every article was i'm never gonna shake
hands again and i'm never gonna go in a
room again and i'll school at home
forever and but
it was just obvious to me that you could
get people to do all sorts of things and
then of course it got worse and worse
and worse because you could get people
to spy on their neighbors you could
demand people inject themselves with
things the same people who said my body
my choice right before and are saying it
again now all of that stuff so the
reason i'm talking about this clip is
it's interesting because
i don't remember bill maher on his show
until the last say two or three months
there was a clip about three months ago
if i'm not mistaken where bill maher
talked about that there shouldn't have
been these lockdowns and vaccine
mandates etc so the point is that
democrats and liberals they get
everything wrong all of the policies
wrong and then when it when it bashes
you in the face that your cities are
burning down and you've ruined all the
businesses and and the kids are getting
stupider and can't talk then finally
they go oh maybe we were kind of right
but they never apologized to the
conservatives uh who were getting it
right the entire time there's still a
bunch of racist buffoons so anyway
that's the theme today that we have to
really start recognizing that some
people do get some stuff right and it
lately at least in the last couple years
it's kind of been let's say conservative
libertarian crew and then there's this
sliver of liberals who get things right
way late but they their need to do some
sort of maya culpa uh and realize that
maybe they ushered in some of this
nonsense right like so again i don't
mean this to attack bill but a guy like
bill who is for
big government he lives in california uh
he likes high taxes and government
programs but then when the government
comes in and does the ppe programs he
talks about how inefficient it is and
how people were stealing the money and a
whole bunch more so that is the general
theme today uh let me talk to you real
quick guys about bonner private wine you
know you've heard me talk about the
amazing extreme altitude wines from the
bonner private wine partnership before i
just had a bottle of their 9 000 foot
malbec the other night at dinner it's
grilling season and the flavors are
great with any meat you're going to have
they're unlike any wine you've ever
tasted it really is true blackberry
leather smoke and a little dark cherry
these wines are almost impossible to get
on your own because the producers are
deep in the andes mountains and they
make a very limited quality quantity
today i have an amazing offer that i've
never had before if you visit bonner
privatewines.com dave you'll not only
get wine for over 50 off plus free
shipping but you'll also get a bonus
bottle of small batch limited production
wine from their exclusive wine cellar
that's four bottles for the price of
three it's a deal that's too hard to
turn down if you're a wine lover like me
just visit bonner privatewise.com dave
to claim your bonus bottle and become
part of america's most unique wine club
okay so
what is the theme once again today the
theme is that there is a series of
people who get most things
wrong
whether it's coveted policy whether it's
crime policy whether there's immigration
policy and then we see the the fruits of
getting these policies wrong and then
they suddenly seem like the good guys
when they realize that everything that
they've been ushering in is bad but we
need to stop playing that game otherwise
what does that do that keeps us on that
endless descent to hell that i'm always
talking about so let's talk a lit a
little bit about crime because crime
across america but especially in blue
cities and blue states is going through
the roof right now and you know it's
going through the roof when even on cnn
they can't deny it here's cnn's john
avalon
talking about the crime situation in
democrat-run cities robbery has jumped
19
but the story in different cities
specifically in different neighborhoods
is all over the map in los angeles
murders hit a 15-year high in the first
six months of the year in philadelphia
the city of brotherly love shootings
have spiked to record highs climbing
hundreds of lives while 100 miles to the
north new york city has seen murders and
shootings actually decline
year-over-year but robberies and
assaults are up big time
now remember these are not just
statistics they are people's lives
okay so that is cnn admitting that
something is going wrong in democrat
cities now who's in charge of
democrat-run cities
democrats it's incredible and uh you may
remember that we had about two years as
the democrats were burning down cities
and you had to board up your store and
say how much you love black lives matter
so that they wouldn't burn your story
down uh the democrats were also
demonizing and defunding the police
something they say now that they didn't
do but we have video of them doing it
so we've been talking about defunding
the police there's some issues that we
ask police to do like mental health
issues or policing in schools and all
the rest that perhaps we can
shuffle some of that money around suck
it up defunding the police has to happen
we need to defund the police mayor eric
garcetti saying take some of the money
from policing about 150 million dollars
i applaud eric garcetti for doing what
he's done not only do we need to
disinvest
foreign police but we need to completely
dismantle the minneapolis police
department so yes defund your butts
defund you yes i support the
reallocation of resources
from nypd we will be moving funding from
the nypd to youth initiatives and social
services yes i support the defund
movement i think you do all those other
things you don't need all the money
that's going in the police department so
yeah i mean the spirit of it i i do
support that defunding police means
defunding police if these reports are
accurate then these proposed cuts to the
nypd budget are a disingenuous illusion
this is not a victory the freshman
democrat adding the fight to defund
policing will continue
okay so as you guys saw at the top of
that clip there are about six more
minutes of that
but we only showed you about a minute of
it but those were officials in places
like minneapolis and places like san
francisco and la
and places like what else was on there
detroit new york city and they are all
democrat run these were their own people
who they voted in to say we would like
less law and order then crime exploded
we'll get into that in just a second
crime explodes all over and then many of
those very same people backtrack their
words because there's a cause right the
cause is defunding the police and the
effect is oh a lot of murder
so this is a problem uh we've got a
quote from the council on criminal
justice which will dive into a little
bit of what's going on here related to
crime
they put out a report this report
updates and supplements previous reports
by the council on criminal justice on
recent u.s crime trends with additional
crime data through june of 2022 so this
is very recent the number of homicides
declined by two percent in the first
half of 2022 compared to the first half
of 2021 a decrease of 54 homicides okay
that's pretty good while this reduction
is heartening the homicide rate is still
39 percent higher than it was during the
first half of 2019 before the covid 19
pandemic you see what's happening here
related to defunding the police domestic
violence incidences decreased by five
percent between the first half of 2021
in the first half of 2022 this result is
based on just 12 cities studied and
should be viewed with caution
residential burglaries were up six
percent non-residential burglaries were
up eight percent larcenies were up 20
and motor vehicle thefts up 15
all increased in the first half of 2022
compared with the first uh the first six
months
of 2021.
so you get it broadly speaking all crime
is going up there are
little incidences where things have gone
down because we had the summer of love
where violence and murder was running
rampant like crazy so there's a if
there's a slight five percent decrease
in certain things it's not something we
should really be uh be you know looking
at and going oh this is just really
spectacular by the way we haven't done
this in a while how many people were
shot and murdered in chicago this past
weekend because we should be out there
marching people i don't know if you guys
are busy for the rest of the day i like
to believe that you have enough work to
be doing how many people shot dead looks
like uh oh only six people were shot
dead over the weekend how many people
were shot
i want to know how many people were shot
because you still it still counts if
you're shot
30 people shot only six shot dead so i
guess that's probably a roughly average
weekend for chicago but the point is the
point i'm trying to illustrate here is
these things are not disconnected when
you when you vote in people who say we
will
take back law enforcement we will
empower criminals we will put more
criminals on the street we will not
abide by law and order well then you get
the results of that so for any of you
who are watching this who are who are
still democrats or have friends or
family who are still democrats it's like
where are the democrats fighting against
this and yes are there a couple does
bill maher try to do it every now and
again yes but if you have no support in
the machine if you have no political
support no people out there leading the
party who are who are going to say no
more of this nonsense then you're pretty
much just yelling
into a void and speaking of people
and speaking of voting for people who
support this nonsense i'm going to show
you two senate candidates running right
now that are still
going for all of this stuff before we
get to that let me talk about mointbox
real quick you know 60 of us pork
production comes from one company owned
by the chinese and their hogs are given
something called ractopamine which is
banned in 160 countries including china
yet you find it in your grocery aisle
every day there's a better way and i
want to tell you about moic that's moo
plus oink moiq delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught alaskan salmon straight to your
door moink farmers farm like our
grandparents did and as a result moiq
menu tastes like it should because the
family farm does it better the moic
difference is a difference you can taste
and you can feel good knowing you're
helping family farms stay financially
independent as well you choose the meat
delivered in every box like rib eyes to
chicken breasts to pork chops pork chops
to salmon fillets and much more plus you
can cancel any time my personal favorite
is their filet mignon which i've served
to the good people in this room right
now shark tank host kevin o'leary called
moinks bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted and ring doorbell founder jamie
simenoff jumped at the chance to invest
in mike plus they'll guarantee you'll
say oink oink i'm just so happy i got
moint
phoenix likes when i read that keep
american farming going by signing up at
moynkbox.com reuben right now and
listeners to this show get a free filet
mignon in every order for a year that's
one of the year's
one of the best filet mignons you'll
ever taste it's m o i n k box dot com
slash rubenbox.com ribbon okay so
you might be watching this program and
going okay dave i get it
we shouldn't be putting people back out
on the streets who are violent criminals
we should be funding the police and
making sure they have the resources to
keep their cities safe actually
when we were showing you that little
clip of all the democrats defunding the
police there's that great moment where
george stephanopoulos uh references eric
garcetti the mayor of los angeles and
says he cut 150 million from the police
budget and kamal harris like yeah that's
great that's great i used to live in l.a
it was a crime infested crap hole the
suburb of miami i'm in right now uh has
not had a home break-in in 12 years
that's the difference when you care
about law and order and you fund the
people who are taking carrier versus
when you defund and all that good stuff
okay the point is there are democrats
right now
it's not just aoc a couple years ago
it's not just ilhan omar it's not just
these clowns gretchen whitmer et cetera
et cetera there are democrats running
right now who are running on the idea
still of defunding the police still of
putting more criminals out in the street
and much more so now here's john
fetterman or fetter woman as he calls
himself again he is the
democrat running for senate in
pennsylvania against dr oz and he wants
to put inmates back out on the street
because that's what people care most
about right now we have a catastrophic
bottleneck in our prisons of over 5 000
men and women condemned to die in prison
and many of them i believe personally
are deserving of a second chance if you
had a magic wand and you could wave it
and fix one thing
what would it be
life without parole in pennsylvania
we could save billions in revenue long
term we could save thousands of lives
and and not make anyone less safe and
also expunge as many permanent records
of people that have been living their
best lives and have been paying well
beyond
when they should have for a charge that
they caught you know 10 15 20 years ago
okay because you guys know i'm fair and
i like given the devil is due first off
i will say that there are probably ways
that we could look at the prison system
and prison reform and figure out ways to
get some people back out on the street
who are non-violent offenders maybe drug
offenders have been there for a long
time or of a certain age etc etc there
are some things we can do about that by
the way there was a guy
who was that guy he was president with
the crazy hair a couple years ago trump
who thank you connor put it
that's good they put it on the
teleprompter for me
trump yeah trump did prison reform and
nobody really gave him any credit for
that if you want more on that you can
watch my interview from earlier in the
week and last week with jared kushner
anyway uh fetterman i'll give him credit
partly right so you got some of that
okay you want to get these people out
what's interesting though is the focus
on that in that fox interview which was
the second part of what we just showed
you the interview is saying what's one
thing that you're really focused on
right now he could have answered
anything well you know we do have crazy
crime and right he's running in
pennsylvania philadelphia is a nightmare
right now he could talk about all the
businesses that were destroyed their
focus on these things is what the
problem is right this guy if you had a
magic wand what would you do man and his
focus is well i'd like to just get more
criminals out on the street this is a
problem but it's also consistent
and it's consistent with a bunch of
people that don't seemingly realize that
they're the ones who have caused their
cities to crumble here is wisconsin's
senate democrat candidate candidate
mandela barnes he's running for senate
in wisconsin right now and he'd like to
empty the prisons too
education immigration reform and
treatment of prisons
in the news a lot lately because we
spent a billion and a half dollars each
year
prisons
he'd like to cut the prison population
in half let's just dump out half of the
inmates and see what happens these are
things that they want to do it sounds
crazy right it sounds absolutely nuts
and i think he said it'll make us safer
that sounds about right
but they keep pushing this and for some
reason their base loves it actually
their base seems to think it's sexy
so i'm happy that we're all here i'm
happy that we're all talking about it
now that uh criminal justice reform and
reducing prison populations is now sexy
it's not a thing that
leading candidates are talking about
because 10 years ago people would have
ran away from this issue people would
have not come up and people would not
have showed up to a forum like this
because they would have been scared they
would look like they were soft on crime
it's sexy man i've never been more
turned on than when a bunch of rapists
get released
into the general population it's so
nuts it's not just backwards right it's
not just incompetence because they have
to see that cause and effect that i
talked about before but it's not just
crime right it's not just crime it's
it's quite literally every single topic
so what else happens with these people
when it comes to immigration right when
trump wanted to build a wall or when any
republican comes in and says hey we have
to be a nation of laws we have to have a
border let's say and that we are a
nation of immigrants but you have to
come here legally and we have to have a
process that makes sense we have to
figure out what do you do with all the
people who are already here illegally et
cetera et cetera they're called racist
and bigoted and xenophobic and
everything else right now we have this
insanely porous uh border thanks to joe
biden and kamala harris and even now
even now we're going to go back to this
uh senate candidate in wisconsin as if
he doesn't realize what allowing all
these illegal immigrants into the
country has done
well he wants to give him driver's
licenses in-state tuition and more
we need an immigration system that
treats all people with dignity and with
respect
a system that says that no human being
is illegal
and in our states we can start by making
sure that immigrants have access to
driver's licenses and in-state college
tuition
because they too are part of our
community but congress must act to
create a path for citizenship
instead of doubling down on a
militarized border wall
see you see why i showed this clip i
don't really care about this guy i don't
know a tremendous amount about the
senate
race in wisconsin okay i don't i'll be
totally honest but you see what he did
there he talks about it in the context
of dignity dignity and respect everyone
should have dignity respect and then of
course he says the line that's complete
nonsense but they love this line no
person is illegal except that's not true
if you are a mexican citizen let's say
or let's say you are a nigerian citizen
and you somehow get to mexico and then
you illegally come through our southern
border and then you are in america or
even let's say you're a canadian refugee
who has good reason to flee justin
trudeau and you somehow illegally come
through our northern border and you
might be white even and i'll say that
because that way people won't call me
racist although they'll do it anyway
you are illegally here by definition you
are breaking the law and if we do not
deal with that within the legal system
then we we simply don't have a country
it's just how it is
so this has very serious consequences
their language and their rhetoric
doesn't match up with reality everyone
has dignity nobody's illegal
okay it just
doesn't
mean anything it simply doesn't mean
anything so you get all these people we
want they don't say they don't say they
want open borders but everyone can kind
of come no one's illegal well guess what
bad things end up happening we've got
some info on what's going on
at our border this is from the new york
post on june 22nd the u.s recorded more
stops along the mexico border fence so
far in fiscal 2022 than in any
accounting year in the 20-year history
of the department of homeland security
with three months still to go in all 207
416 migrant encounters were recorded in
june according to u.s customs and border
protection for a total of over 1.7
million stops along the southern border
since october 1st the most the agency
has recorded for any fiscal year since
1960 and the number of migrant
encounters along the southern border hit
that mark despite dropping 14 in june
from may's record high according to data
released by the byte administration
friday nationwide border officials have
encountered more than 2 million migrants
since october 1st 2021.
prior to last month the highest number
of migrants encountered in a fiscal year
was 1.7 million
in 2021 before that the highest was 1.6
in year 2000. so what's interesting
about this is when our administration
basically says hey we're not going to
really protect the border
people start pouring in then when people
start pouring in what happens well in a
place like a border town of texas a far
right latina
some far right latina myra flores wins
what was a democrat seat for a hundred
years because people have had it and
people want legal immigration not
illegal immigration and then what
happens well finally when enough people
realize that people are pouring through
the border that no one is in charge of
this
suddenly the media two years too late
again that's the theme that the media
always the media and the quote-unquote
saying dems they always catch up way too
late then they start asking questions
here's nbc's chuck todd asking kamala
about the border this is just a day or
two ago would you call the border secure
i think that there is no question that
we have to do what the president and i
asked congress to do the first request
we made
pass
a
bill
to create a pathway to citizenship the
border is secure but we also have a
broken immigration system in particular
over the last four years before we came
in and it needs to be fixed we're gonna
have two million people cross this
border for the first time ever you're
confident this border's secure
we have
a secure border
in that that is a priority for any
nation including ours in our
administration
she is so extraordinarily vapid like
that's the only thing you could say
about her right it's like man between
her and buying it's like biden doesn't
know what he's saying and we'll just
read anything with her it's as if they
put her out there having no knowledge of
anything and she strings together words
in the most circular way to say
absolutely
nothing chuck is doing the best job he
could there hey a lady you know two
million people are coming in that's an
awful lot of people uh
this thing's secure and then she just
says well we have a policy of a policy
and it's a policy blah blah blah okay so
again the cause and effect situation
here is in full effect bad policies lead
to crazy things happening and then crazy
things actually then reverberate when a
crazy thing happens at the federal level
it may start in a border town of texas
but then it reverberates throughout the
nation so this video is absolutely
spectacular this happened a couple days
ago if you did not see it it's just so
wonderful so you guys know what's going
on the biden administration basically is
not taking care of the border as chuck
said about two million people are going
to run through this year then what
happens in texas and in florida because
we have sane functioning governors our
governors are now bussing illegal
immigrants to washington dc which is a
wonderful plan they don't have to stay
here and if we don't want them here that
is the policy of these states
unfortunately we have states rights and
we're going to send them to dc now dc
muriel bowser is the mayor of dc and
they've got a whole bunch of council
people over there who want it to be a
sanctuary city and nobody's illegal it's
all of the stuff that sounds sort of
right but then in a functional way does
not work so we covered it i think a week
or two ago that in dc all of their
homeless shelters are now being filled
up with illegals so this video came out
this is dc councilwoman brienne nadew
and she is very upset because now dc is
being overrun by the by the very people
that she wanted to come into the country
as long as they were going to stay in
texas
so
it's been said but it's worth
reiterating that the governors of texas
and arizona have created this crisis
and the federal government has not
stepped up to assist the district of
columbia so we
along with our regional partners will do
what we've always done we'll rise to the
occasion
we've learned from border towns
like el paso and brownsville
and in many ways
the governors of texas and arizona
have turned us into a border town we
don't know how long this will take
to resolve we don't know how long they
will continue busing and so the right
thing to do here is to be prepared to
ensure we can greet every bus we can get
people off on the right foot we can get
them where they want to go
and that will ultimately help them in
their
i mean liberal logic it basically makes
people stupid
this woman okay so first off she's
saying it's it's the governors of texas
and arizona that are doing this now of
course as you know but she's somewhat
dim
the federal government is in charge of
our borders so she may not be happy that
the governors of texas and arizona and
florida are bussing people to d.c but
it's not their fault in the first place
the fault lies with the people that are
in charge of the border that's her party
right that's old joe and confused kamala
so that's number one then she says
something that really shows you what
these people are now she's very upset
and why is she upset because dc is
becoming a border town
but what do you mean a border town would
be full of immigrants and you'd think it
would be very
diverse very pluralistic and everybody
would be having a great time and there'd
be no crime what's the matter with
border towns or is for some reason she's
okay with border towns as long as
they're in texas and arizona but not in
dc and then at the end of course she
says but we'll do what we do which is
rise to the uh rise to it and we will
get to it and we're going to take care
of these people we will rise to the
moment and what she means by that is we
are going to take more tax money from
legal people and we are going to fund it
into programs that will do absolutely
nothing keep a certain set of people
here illegally we're going to keep them
in the welfare state it's going to
increase crime blah blah blah anyway i
say have out of dc enjoy um
speaking of ridiculous people here's
lori lightfoot
and in lori lightfoot's case what did
she say well you know uh she's upset too
that they're busting him over to her
chicago mayor lori lightfoot said that
migrants are being placed on buses with
a lack of dignity to an unknown
destination with very little food very
little water
she of course is the same lori lightfoot
who
as daphne pointed out six people killed
in chicago this weekend not a lot of
dignity there 30 people shot
she also wants chicago
to be a sanctuary city so if you're
saying hey we're a sanctuary city we
take care of everybody again it sounds
good don't work
well then you're gonna get all of this
so what is the point of everything i'm
saying
they're failing up they push their
stupid rhetoric and no matter how many
times it is proven wrong and and quite
literally dangerous these people still
get people to vote for them and then
they feel the terrible consequences of
all of that and then of course they run
for higher and higher office but now
let's link this to the media too because
it's not just politicians who do all of
the wrong things and then get better
gigs right get move all the way up uh
cnn's brian stelter well
i should say
brian stelter formerly of cnn as you
know one of the things that happened in
august was he got fired now i don't take
great joy in someone losing their job
but he was in complete dereliction of
his duty this was not someone who
deserved to be the host of a show called
reliable sources which was supposed to
hold the media to account i think i've
mentioned this a few times i used to
watch the show as a kid i remember on
sunday mornings i would watch the show i
really enjoyed it even as a kid i guess
i'm doing the right thing for a living
because it was about
how the media should cover stories how
the media should frame things then
stelter made it what everything else is
which is just sort of a democrat lie
laundering machine well here is stelter
this is about a year ago maybe a year
and a half ago in the height of all the
lunacy when he was defending uh defund
the police but look to be clear this is
a police-free zone mostly police freak
some police have come in it amounts to
about six blocks look at this map okay
it looks pretty big if you show the map
right really zoomed in but when you zoom
way out you see this is just a small
part of seattle now here's what fox news
did on the web we can go let's zoom the
map out let's just go ahead and show the
zoomed out map if we can i just want to
make the point this is a small part of a
big city and that's not being reflected
in the coverage
okay so why am i showing you this what
he's trying to do what he was trying to
do then is i see fox is making it sound
like crime is running rampant there but
this is really just a small area in
seattle and there isn't crime running
ramp and even though cops can't go there
and yes some couple people got raped and
murdered or whatever but uh he's just
obfuscating what the obvious truth was
which is that you can't have a just a
police-free zone you can't have little
banta states within cities and all of
those things actually connor over here
used to live he pointed out them up you
live two blocks away from choppy you
could point to it on that thing
how was it over there
terrible it was not good okay that's the
point it was not good there but now why
am i talking about this because stelter
with his idiotic rhetoric the
implication being that the people at fox
news somehow hate black people or poor
people or aren't for black lives matters
or whatever he got it obviously
completely wrong and it was a disaster
and seattle uh will take probably
decades to get out of the crap that
they're in because of all this so what
happens to selterman he gets fired and
then he gets fired but
democrat so what happens you fell up
from outkick former cnn host brian
stelter has a new job he has joined
harvard to warn students of threats
against democracy
i think he's just going to stand in
front of the
in front of the kids big fat guy big fat
man shirt and just write me on it
threats to democracy but you fail i mean
really think about that you get fired
from cnn the most beclownish news
network in the history of all time
and then what happens you get fired in
disgrace like actually in disgrace
because you're so bad at your job and
then you get a gig at harvard like you
didn't get a gig at nassau community
college
no offense i'm from long island it was
just the one that popped into my head i
knew a lot of people that went there he
got a gig at what is thought of as the
best ivy league school in the united
states which is systemically racist
against asians you guys know all about
that but they fell up that is the point
much like the politicians and speaking
of failing up uh you may remember a
woman by the name of jen saki
we haven't talked about her in a while
uh well she worked for the elderly man
pretending to be president joe biden and
old joe also was all about defunding the
police
surplus military equipment for law
enforcement they don't need that the
last thing you need is an up armored
humvee coming into a neighborhood it's
like the military invading they don't
know anybody they become the enemy
they're supposed to protecting these
people so my generic point is that do we
agree that we can redirect some of the
funding
yes
absolutely
okay so that was joe biden a couple
years back he wanted to redirect funding
he wanted to make sure police didn't
have all the resources they need again
we can discuss whether they should have
certain things or not it's a
separate idea but he's the head he's the
titular head of the party i think that's
what they say the titular head and uh
yeah i like how he said i'm making my
generic point everything you do is
generic you fool uh anyway but he was
for defunding the police uh and now how
do i link this to failing up well you
may remember jen saki and of course she
was a professional liar she always lied
about everything and one of the things
she was always lying about was whether
the administration and biden were really
for defunding the police or not it's
made available thank you and on the rise
in violent crime i compared to this time
last year homicides up 113 minneapolis
up 38 in philly up 22 in chicago uh just
to clarify the white house's position on
this is that that is mostly because of
guns
well first i'm not sure what data you're
looking at but i think what we can most
data that is out there shows that
there's actually been a rise in crime
over the course of the last year since
the start of the pandemic which actually
predates president biden taking office
to be totally clear
you're right you're right you're right
peter and that's why we're we are
focused well we're focused on uh
solutions here and that's why we
proposed uh putting a fight we put five
billion dollars in the american jobs
plan to help address community violent
intervention programs to help fund them
that's also why we fought for funding
for state and local governments in the
rescue plan something
many opposed there was a lot of
republican opposition to that st louis
says that she believes more police does
not prevent crime does president biden
agree with that the president believes
there's a number of steps that need to
be taken to rebuild trust in communities
police reform is long outdated he also
believes that there needs to be funding
for local programs and local initiatives
and there's not going to be a shortage
of funding under our watch
sorry i showed her i forgot what that
was like the point is she's just saying
a whole bunch of nothing but in essence
they were for defunding the police then
at the end it's like oh we throw a bunch
of money at stuff and we'll move money
over here and over there and blah blah
blah but i think we can all agree that
she was pretty terrible at her job so
what happens in the world of democrat
media politics and the constant blow job
that that thing is well gensake
yesterday on the twitter first day new
job thrilled and honored to be here with
this remarkable team see you soon on tv
and that is her nbc universal pass
jennifer saki and yes it seems that she
will be getting a show on msnbc so you
are a horrible
a horrible bounty hunter you are a paid
liar for an administration a woman who
could not say anything true who i often
said her head was like this because the
truth wants to come out of you and she
was trying to lock it in
what happens
much like brian stelter you get fired
you get a gig at harvard you you step
down really
in
you should be ashamed of yourself for
what you did for a year and you get a
job at a corporate news network uh so
uh as saki would say to circle back to
where we started the democrats are
basically getting everything wrong and
we cannot forget that they get
everything wrong and seemingly don't
seemingly don't learn their lessons
along the way so let's go back to sort
of where we started today
cnn john avlon
basically telling to democrat telling
democrats there's a problem here
when the state legislature finally acted
on criminal justice this summer they
decided to focus on semantics instead of
solutions officially replacing the term
inmate with incarcerated person in state
laws seriously that's what they did
now sometimes we forget that public
safety is a fundamental civil right and
it's often lower income neighborhoods
that suffer the most from high crime
while wealthier neighborhoods stay
relatively safe
in fact black and hispanic democrats are
more likely than white democrats to
support increased spending on local
police that's according to a pew survey
from late last year
look politicizing crime seeks to gain
from other people's pain but trying to
ignore crime for ideological reasons is
both callous and clueless and it's sure
to promote a political backlash
look at me
i'm gonna pat myself on the back showing
cnn doing something sane and isn't that
something that that the black and
hispanic community i hate that phrase uh
that in this at least one pew poll that
they're referencing there that they want
more local policing than the white
people i mean it's just so perfect but
if a black person was to say that to a
white liberal they would call them a
self-hating black person i mean it's
just so bananas so what do you do what
is the solution ladles and jelly spoons
you must make a decision if you are a
democrat or a friend of a democrat we're
arming you with information here we're
arming you with arguments and
information we all know these people who
are still bamboozled who are still
trying to break out of their factory
settings
but they can be gotten to i really
believe it there's not many people who
can move one way or another who are
going to potentially vote in a different
way this november than they would have
in the past but i think the democrats
who are not completely
mind-melted at this point are the ones
that we can get to
and one of them is tulsi gabbard we need
a
unifying president someone who will
bring our country together and
unfortunately what we're seeing from
president biden and his administration's
the exact opposite
they are pouring fuel on the flames of
divisiveness they are attacking and
targeting anyone who dared to vote
against president biden or anyone who
dares to disagree with his views
demonizing them and and frankly
portraying them as extremists who pose a
very direct threat uh to our country
it's clear that through his speech
through his actions and policies he
cares more about power than he does
about the freedom and well-being of the
american people
i mean i've said it a bajillion times
but just imagine what a different
situation we might be in
if the democrats when they cut all the
backdoor deals had gone with tulsi as vp
instead of kamala harris imagine what a
moderating effect that might have had
and when they put that woman out an
active member of our military who's a
proud american
who is more lefty than i am
uh
imagine how different that would be than
when they put out kamala who has no idea
what she's saying i mean it would be so
fundamentally different that would have
been the chance but the point is they
always miss their chance and do you know
why because they've become the party of
no common sense but who said that it
wasn't me oh that was bill maher just a
day or two ago
i think they're going to get
thumped in the election i mean that
usually happens in midterm elections but
you know i mean joe look i'm glad he's
there
but uh he has not exactly stuck the
landing on a lot of the issues that he
was dealing with i keep saying this to
the democratic party
the reason why you're so toxic is
because you have become
the party of no common sense
well well what do you mean you're glad
he's there what do you mean you're glad
joe biden's there are you glad that we
left afghanistan the way that we did are
you glad that the deficit is through the
roof are you glad that the supply chain
ain't working are you glad that gas
prices were through the roof now they're
coming down a little bit so the
administration is going see gas prices
are coming down but it's like they're
still higher than when you got there
okay fine that so many things are a
problem but you're glad he's there
meaning you're glad orange man isn't
there
and and that's what i'm gonna hopefully
work on a little bit uh with bill maher
but yes the democrats are no longer the
party of common sense perhaps they never
were but there is nothing
commonsensical about the democrats
anymore which is why i always say you
don't have to be a republican but you
cannot be a democrat these people all
have to go
and and if that means that the radical
base that the progressive woke lunatics
and the genderless whack-a-doodles and
all of that stuff that they fully take
over that party well then so be it
because they've taken it over already
and and some of the people who are the
quasi-moderates they're just making it
seem like it's not as bad as it is but
it is and the funny thing is and and
bill if you're watching this and i'll
hopefully get to say it to you next week
you could look at my life as an example
of what could happen you can be invited
to all of the republican and libertarian
and right-leaning events that i go to
and you bill maher the the biggest
liberal atheist in the country could
probably get the invite to liberty
university you could speak at all of the
conservative college events that i go to
you could tell them that you have
disagreements with them as i do and
you'd be applauded for it and then what
you might be able to do bill maher or
tulsi gabbard or anyone else that's in
this space you might actually be able to
moderate the conservatives a little bit
you might be able to carve out a little
place of common sense on the republican
side
and i bet you you could i will bet i
do i have five dollars here
i will bet you five american dollars
that if tulsi or bill maher or any one
of these you know quote-unquote same
liberals that if they would just start
going to the republicans a little bit
more going to the conservatives talking
at their events they will find nothing
but goodness and it does not mean that
they're betraying what they believe it
doesn't mean that they're going to get
everything they want but it will be a
hell of a lot better than the scorched
earth
and the endless descent to hell that
they're on right now
that's how i feel about that uh we got a
cold close for you in just a moment let
me get to a couple comments at
reubenreport.locals.com
chris says isn't that the platform that
bain ran his campaign on in dark knight
rises
bane did run an interesting campaign you
know you can't leave nothing for
everybody else and we're going to have
to take down everybody in wall street
good movie man i missed those trilogy by
the way the new batman which i saw a
couple weeks ago was absolutely
fantastic uh tony says bill maher can
bloviate all he wants and point out
problems but if
but if he refuses to get behind the
solution he's no help well look that's
what i that's what i want to talk to him
about it's like if you get there if you
get there
then what what is the last thing that
you're afraid of
like is it really that you think all of
these people are religious whack jobs
they're not
they're not and it might say something
about religious people if all of the
religious people are the ones defending
the world that you want to live in so
hopefully we can have that conversation
ta says even fauci is trying to walk
back that he never ordered lockdowns
yeah well that's the thing you know it's
rats on a ship at this point they are
all going to reverse everything that
they said all and that's what i mean
about all of the people that they get
there late fauci's like a particularly a
particular example of evil because he
was guiding so much of it and the way he
would you know if you criticize me
you're criticizing science like
he's a very bad version of it but we
just can't forget all of the people that
were joyously calling for lockdowns the
people i mean there were main
stream journalists and politicians who
wanted people fired from their job
if they did not get an injection and
they are the same people who right now
related to abortion will be screaming my
body my choice we cannot forget these
people we must re remember it we must
remember it because guess what guys
mark my words conor can you put a little
note in today's episode for dave's words
to be marked it's going to happen again
whether it is covid 2 or it's monkey pox
7 or they it's a zombie apocalypse or a
climate emergency or whatever they will
try all of this again it may not look
exactly the same but the markers will be
there the same because this was a test
you know that that jordan peterson video
i always show you guys when he's on
rogan talking about how do you encroach
on people you don't take everything at
once you push you see what pushback
there is you push again you see what
pushback and i think for the most part
the powers that be
they got us all to fold they got us all
to fold with little pockets of
resistance
guys we happen to live in one of those
little pockets of resistance which is
pretty sweet to think you you lived a
block away from chop i saved your life
man
you gotta
thank me i hope you wake up every
morning going thank god for dave rubin
on that note guys if you're watching on
youtube why don't you jump over to
rumble.com reubenreport and watch us
over there
and of course we are always always at
reubenreport.locals.com
i've enjoyed the program today part one
of vivec ramaswamy really interesting
interview this guy is a vc guy who is
trying to figure out is there a way to
do true stakeholder capitalism where
actually your interests will have a
little something to do with where you
put your money and that you're not just
going to fund your own demise by putting
your money into these funds that are
going to push all this woke nonsense
really interesting part one is up on
rumble they're up already right
yeah yes uh part one's up on rumble on
youtube right now full things up over at
locals and we have a cold clothes for
you it's joe biden struggling once again
goodbye
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops thank you for listening
[Music]
jack come on back up
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
keep up the fight thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you